chill away the second largest island in
Chile is home to more than 150,000
people life here has changed
dramatically over the past few months
Marcelo carrusca for instance is a
muscle farmer who's lost everything when
I bahrami this is actually the best part
of the beach we waited for four years
for the muscles to get big enough to
harvest but just as we were preparing to
do that the algae bloom came and killed
all the muscles algae bloom is a rapid
increase in algea that's deadly not just
a shellfish but also toxic to humans all
fishing and mussel farming has been
prohibited here it may take months until
the authorities lift the ban the
region's salmon farmers have also been
hard hit by the algae bloom after Norway
Chile is the world's largest producer of
salmon the industry is worth billions
but the algae bloom destroyed twenty
percent of fish stocks the salmon simply
suffocated the dead fish had to be
removed and the Chilean government
allowed the farmers to simply dump 4,000
tons of them into the open sea for the
head of Chile's largest some and
producer it's an economic disaster the
calculation is something in the
neighborhood of 200 million dollar of
fish biomass being lost because of the
algae bloom and this is one of the items
because after that you have to count the
the cause of being away from the market
experts say the Chilean salmon industry
will lose around half a billion euros
this year that will have trickle-down
effects 45,000 people on the island work
in the salmon industry there have
already been redundancies
the algae bloom problem affects life on
all parts of the island vendors can no
longer get any fresh where's so fish
markets have closed and tourists have
stayed away because restaurants can
offer any typical Island specialties
these stalls used to be open every day
everyone came to buy things here seafood
is used to make our local dishes Toronto
and empanadas de lys but now it's all
gone and I don't know when they will
reopen Marcelo Carrasco has been out of
work for five months and is getting
desperate he lives alone with his
five-year-old daughter saying when are
you then you're not but you can invite I
had some savings that I was going to use
to finish building the house but instead
I had to spend them all on my daughter
she needs to eat I need to pay for her
expenses getting her to school in her
lunch money nado lo capo Bowden la amo
lo que con sumitomo seguida de puede
tomar para papa porque gente y ahora
Carrasco is one of thousands of
frustrated fishermen when recently they
blockaded all points of entry to the
island in protest I evening workers and
tourists were stranded and there were
shortages of food and gasoline the
fishermen say the Chilean government
isn't doing enough to help and that
authorities shouldn't have allowed four
thousand tons of dead fish to be dumped
into the sea they say that just makes
the algae bloom worse Carrasco and the
other fishermen say they were protest
again and not so peacefully this time
it's not clear what caused the algae
bloom scientists don't even know how it
started they need time to carry out
tests but they already suspect that
unusually warm waters caused by the El
Nino climate phenomenon played an
important role the Chilean fishing
industry is considering how it can
protect itself in future against further
algae bloom outbreaks probably had to
find some some technology in trying to
escape down in in this cages so in order
to avoid the algae bloom which is in the
in the upper part of the ocean probably
some some technology would have to be a
priority to move the cages in this
direction if the residents of Chihuahua
are to survive the salmon industry and
the fishermen must find a way of
mitigating any future damage from the
deadly algae